die angst vor den mutationen österreich
warnt vor reisen nach tirol und
deutschland debattiert über das für und
wider von lockerungen es hört nicht auf
der schnee lähmt den verkehr in weiten
teilen des landes eine knackig kalte
woche steht den meisten bevor und
triumph an der amerikanischen legende
football star tom brady gewinnt mit 43
jahren zum siebten mal den super bowl
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten um 7 norbert lehmann ist
auch dabei für den sport eine schöne
guten beamter von mir
zwei tage vor dem nächsten bund länder
treffen zur coroner lage werden fragen
nach lockerungen immer drängender
vor allem die öffnung von schulen und
kitas wird heftig diskutiert
aber auch die wirtschaft appelliert an
die bundesregierung den schatten zu
beenden um wieder eine perspektive zu
haben wurden dem rkw zu jahresbeginn im
schnitt noch mehr als 20.000
neuinfektion täglich gemeldet so hat
sich die zahl inzwischen mehr als
halbiert in der vergangenen woche
steckten sich noch durchschnittlich 8
1637 menschen neu an die sieben tage
incidents pro 100000 einwohner sinkt auf
76 also der moment für lockerungen
experten sagen nein
und warnen vor den mutanten des virus
vor allem der britischen und der
südafrikanischen ein wichtiger punkt
gerade wenn man darüber nachdenkt die
schulen wieder zu öffnen
matthias kugel zahl zuckertüte
klassenzimmer zusammen sein
so ging das schuljahr los drei monate
später stühle hoch zu hause lernen
gäbe es eine alternative trotz corona ja
mit disziplin und strengen regeln sagt
jetzt eine wissenschaftliche leitlinien
wenn schulen geöffnet werden dann
sollten die maßnahmen zur prävention und
kontrolle der saas kopf zwei übertragung
insgesamt sehr sehr konsequent ausfallen
viel konsequenter noch als in der
vergangenheit
dutzende experten aus virologie bis
psychologie werteten 40 studien aus und
empfehlen für den cobit schulalltag
zusätzlich zum masken tragen gruppen
bilden versetzt unterrichten alle 20
minuten drei bis fünf minuten lüften
musikunterricht ohne singen sport nur
draußen und verdachtsfälle immer ernst
nehmen
schnee von gestern kritisieren die
grünen ihre forderung das ffp zwei
masten an den schulen zur verfügung
gestellt werden
das corona selbst
an den schulen auch an den kitas
flächendeckend zur verfügung gestellt
werden auch die bundesfamilienministerin
drängt auf tests in schulen und kitas
es ist ein appell jetzt auch an die
länder diese strategien umzusetzen damit
wir entsprechend auch zu einer höheren
sicherheit kommen zurückhaltend zur
schule öffnungen kabinettskollege sparen
wegen der noch zu hohen incidents zahlen
sie singt sie sind ein ermutigender
größenordnung wir sehen also die
maßnahmen wirken aber aus heutiger sicht
ist es sicherlich noch nicht so dass
alles ab dem 15 februar wieder so sein
kann wie es im oktober war dass die
stühle in den schulen also schon sehr
bald wieder unten stehen
unwahrscheinlich ja das klingt alles
nicht gerade nach öffnungen ab mitte
februar theo sieht es am mittwoch also
eher nach einer verlängerung des
schattens aus ja ich glaube davon kann
man ausgehen dass ab heute nachmittag
eine schaltkonferenz der chefs der
staatskanzleien die die sitzung am
mittwoch vorbereiten und da war nach dem
was wir hören große übereinstimmungen
den shutter und für weitere zwei wochen
zu verlängern und man will für danach
also ab dem ersten märz eine öffnung
score beschreiben also unter welchen
bedingungen was und wie geöffnet werden
kann
unter anderem wird offensichtlich an
einem rechenmodell gearbeitet es nicht
nur den berühmten inzidenz wert von 50 1
bezieht sondern auch wie sind die
impfzahlen wie ist der r wehrt und wie
ist die ausbreitung der mutation all das
kombiniert könnte dann ein wert ergeben
der den ländern und kommunen die
möglichkeiten einräumen bei
entsprechenden bedingungen zu lockern
heute abend telefonieren die
ministerpräsidenten um den mittwoch
vorzubereiten entscheidungen sind
natürlich noch keine gefallen aber der
trend scheint stand jetzt relativ klar
erstmal zwei wochen verlängerung zu
shutter interessanter plan vielen dank
theo koll in berlin für das personal in
kliniken gibt es noch einmal eine corona
prämie als anerkennung für die
erschwerten arbeitsbedingungen und die
psychischen belastungen
die sonderzahlung von bis zu 1500 euro
soll bis mitte des jahres ausgezählt
werden vom bonus sollen nicht nur
sondern zum beispiel auch
reinigungskräfte profitieren
die kosten belaufen sich insgesamt auf
450 millionen euro
seit heute ist eine neue coruna im
verordnung in kraft neu daran ist dass
menschen mit schweren vorerkrankungen
wie krebs und diabetes unter bestimmten
bedingungen jetzt früher geimpft werden
nämlich in gruppe 2 dagegen müssen
lehrerinnen erzieher ärzte und ärztinnen
weiter auf ihre impftermine warten bis
ende märz sollen alle über 80 jährigen
die das wollen geimpft seien
mitarbeitende in heimen auf
intensivstationen und bei
rettungsdiensten bekommen vorrangig das
mittel von astrazeneca das nur für
menschen bis 64 jahre vorgesehen ist ein
ritt auf der rasierklinge
so hat ein politiker jüngst die abwägung
zwischen corona shutdown und lockerungen
in österreich beschrieben
am ende dieses ergebnis viele läden
schulen und frisiersalons sind etwa ab
sofort unter auflagen wieder offen um
auch die schäden abseits von cobit 19
abzumildern
aber es gibt eine besonderheit eine
reisewarnung innerhalb des eigenen
landes für tirol weil dort die
hochansteckende südafrikanische mutante
kassiert britta hilpert auch in tirols
landeshauptstadt innsbruck genießen sie
das shoppen die lockerungen
doch bei manchen mischt sich
unsicherheit in die erleichterung die
hochansteckende südafrikanische mutante
ist in tirol hundertfach nachgewiesen
man sieht vielleicht auch friseure sind
auf jeden fall wieder von vorteil dass
die offen sind aber eigentlich würde ich
mir wünschen dass alles weiter
geschlossen bleibt
das ist vielfach nicht wie es andere
corona seit ende dezember war alles zu
in österreich die lager übervoll der
druck der wirtschaft zu öffnen groß so
fährt das land nun eine doppelstrategie
man darf wieder einkaufen aber nur mit f
e p2 maske und platzbeschränkungen man
darf zum friseur und zu anderen
körpernahen
dienstleistungen aber nur mit negativ
test und man darf wieder in die schule
aber nur im schichtbetrieb und nach
selbst testen
trotzdem bleibt sorge habe wirklich
echte bedenken ob wir gesund wie aus
dieser situation wieder hinaus kommen
wollen weil er die fallzahlen in
österreich nach wie vor auf einem
relativ hohen niveau eigentlich stabil
aber auf keinen fall
dort sind wo wir eigentlich hin wollten
aus tirol so fürchten manche könnte
wieder eine infektionswelle heranrollen
wer nicht ganz oder in teilen
abgeschottet wird vor einem jahr
entstand in ischgl in tirol europas
erster großer hotspot es könnte nun ein
zweites ich gegeben waren virologen doch
die regierung von sebastian kurz scheut
davor zurück tirol abzuschotten schaut
zurück vor unpopulären maßnahmen
österreichs regierung rät nur
unverbindlich ab von reisen nach tirol
und empfiehlt es sollte man kürzlich
dort gewesen sein und damit zum zweiten
großen thema dieser tage dem
extremwetter vor allem im norden und in
der mitte deutschlands fällt auch zum
start der arbeitswoche weiter reichlich
neuschnee
mit dem satz es ist halt winter sind für
viele menschen die mengen die da bis zur
stunde vom himmel gekommen sind nicht
mehr hinreichend beschrieben
das land liegt quasi unter einer ice
glocke nur der süden ist in teilen
schnee frei geblieben in den nächsten
stunden kommt dann vor allem an der
ostsee noch mal einiges an niederschlag
dazu thomas konsum
schnee satt
staus ein schwerer wochenstart einer mit
wintersport erzwungenermaßen so geht es
wie in göttingen manchmal schneller zur
arbeit als mit dem auto
denn das muss man erst mal finden und
befreien
ich muss zur arbeit aber ich denke das
wird nix eine stunde
das maß per zollstock 30 cm weiße berge
im flachen niedersachsen zu viel winter
auch in leipzig für busse und
straßenbahnen niemand wird hier verletzt
der schienenverkehr
er ist überhaupt vielerorts auf eis
gelegt alle hauptstrecken sollen erst
morgen wieder frei sein
reisende sind gestrandet etwa im bremer
schnee warten und nochmals warten auch
auf autobahnen über bad hersfeld hessen
vor allem auf anhöhen passiert ein lkw
bleibt stecken nachfolgende ebenfalls
rettungsdienste helfen so gut es denn
geht wenn ihnen nicht selbst geholfen
werden muss und noch was macht
schwierigkeiten rücksichtslosigkeit wir
sind bis zur einsatzstelle schlecht
durchgekommen weil viele autofahrer die
rettungsgasse nicht gebildet haben und
dort wo der schnee flog in der
rettungsgasse gefahrenes haben sich
einige autofahrer genau in diese gast
herein gestellt und wollten dort
mitfahren eiskalt bleibt es übrigens auf
dem land in städten und an der see
der winter zeigt weiter seine zähne
tja und jetzt schauen wir nach thüringen
das liegt komplett unter schnee und es
bleibt winterlich dort und sehr frostig
die temperaturen im keller - gerade tag
und nacht die landeshauptstadt steht
mehr oder weniger still aus dem tief
verschneiten erfurt daniela sonntag
sie kamen nicht weit staub auf erfurts
straßenbahnschienen und mancher fahrer
kann vom feierabend nur träumen
wenn ich diese seite 35 europa braucht
straße doch dann die fünf stunden lang
bis ich mich befreit haben und jetzt
stehe ich stattdessen für viele erfurter
heute winterwandern in der innenstadt
ich mach kurzen stadtbummel denn mit den
auto kein weg kommen kein durchkommen in
vielen teilen thüringens bis zu 30
zentimeter neuschnee
gepaart mit eisglätte und berufsverkehr
das sorgte für probleme bei
waltershausen trifft es diesen lkw
gleich zweimal
der stand zuerst um dort ein bahngleis
der thüringer wald bauen da haben wir
ausziehen können und kurze zeit später
auch standort im stadtgebiet noch mal
auf kreuzungen und kam dort nicht mehr
vorstellen
manche orte ganz abgeschnitten in burg
tonner muss das thw die einzige
zufahrtsstraße zum ortsteil freiräumen
und wer dachte besser umsteigen auf die
bahn hatte pech bahnknotenpunkt erfurt
einzug nur zum aufwärmen und warten
ich bin eigentlich schon vergessen da
ich weiß im hotel eincheckte der
winterdienst unterwegs die post nicht
fast keine zustellung heute in thüringen
die straßenbahn in erfurt immerhin frei
gepokert nach zehn stunden stau doch
auch morgen ist hier noch mit
einschränkungen zu rechnen
zur politik da haben die linken heute
einen entwurf für ihr wahlprogramm
vorgelegt kernpunkte sind etwa eine
vier-tage-woche höhere renten mehr
mindestlohn und keine auslandseinsätze
der bundeswehr
die beiden vorsitzenden katja kipping
und bernd riexinger hatten zuletzt immer
wieder ein mögliches regierungsbündnis
mit spd und grünen nach der
bundestagswahl ins spiel gebracht bernd
benthin berichtet
bernd nicht vors logo mahnt die
ko-vorsitzende bei der vorstellung heute
soll wirklich alles sitzen nach
schwierigen zeiten hofft die linke auf
neue chancen und neue bündnisse im
superwahljahr
die korona krise hat gezeigt der markt
regelt nichts wir müssen den markt
regeln
zudem sagen wir ganz klar nach 16 jahren
cdu im bundeskanzleramt es ist nun zeit
für soziale mehrheiten unter anderem
fordert die linke ein mindesteinkommen
von 1200 euro
sie spricht von einem linken green new
deal und will dafür etwa den
öffentlichen nahverkehr gratis anbieten
38 milliarden euro soll das kosten und
die 30 stunden arbeitswoche soll zum
standard werden über die finanziellen
auswirkungen sagt die partei dabei
nichts
wir meinen wir haben so hohe
produktivität dass die arbeit mehr um
das leben kreisen kann als dass das
ganze leben um die arbeit reißen muss
zur finanzierung der vorhaben soll es
eine einmalige vermögensabgabe geben und
darüber hinaus auch eine vermögenssteuer
deutschland ist eines der wenigen länder
die keine vermögenssteuer kennen auch
mit einem freibetrag von einer million
und bei betriebsvermögen von 5.000.000
damit würden rund 100 milliarden mehr in
die öffentlichen kassen gespült
im sommer soll der entwurf auf einem
parteitag beschlossen werden vorher aber
wählt die linke noch neue
parteivorsitzende digital ende februar
deutschland schweden und polen weisen
jeweils einen russischen diplomaten aus
und reagieren damit auf einen
entsprechenden schritt moskau die
russische regierung hatte am freitag
insgesamt drei diplomaten der eu länder
ausgewiesen und ihnen vorgeworfen an
einer illegalen demonstration für den
kremlkritiker alexei navalny
teilgenommen zu haben
in israel wird in sechs wochen wieder
gewählt ministerpräsident netanjahu will
sich im wahlkampf als erfolgreicher
corona manager präsentieren
heute musste er aber erst einmal vor
gericht erscheinen
dort wies er die korruptionsvorwürfe
gegen sich zurück
ihm wird unter anderem zur last gelegt
medienunternehmer begünstigt zu haben
michael war
normalerweise ist für jene tanja dafür
bekannt aus jedem noch so kleinen
auftritt werbung in eigener sache zu
machen
im gericht heute dreht er den kameras
den rücken zu kein statement wie beim
prozessauftakt nur dieses er bekräftigt
vor gericht den antrag seiner anwälte
nicht schuldig es geht in drei fällen um
korruption betrug untreue im vielleicht
brisantesten soll netanya dem inhaber
eines telekom-konzerns profite in
milliarden-höhe zugeschanzt haben im
gegenzug habe die internetzeitung des
konzerns systematisch positiv über
netanjahu berichtet der prozess kommt
für viele beobachter zur unzeit corona
längst nicht ausgestanden die koalition
geplatzt im märz neuwahlen die vierten
in zwei jahren abschreiben würden ihn
aber die wenigsten
bisher gibt es keine anzeichen für
auswirkungen auf seine politische lage
vielleicht sogar das gegenteil
netanjahu hat noch viele unterstützer
und streut immer wieder vorwürfe gegen
ermittler und gerichte vor dem gericht
sind allerdings die gegner am
lautstärksten selten hat ein prozess das
land so polarisiert wie dieser für die
einen wie die demonstranten hier ist
tanja und drei minister der verbrechens
minister doch für anhänger schaffen sich
es geht um grundsätzliches
ich stehe hier für die demokratie und in
der muss ein premier bei einer so
schweren anklage ins gefängnis dass
netanyahu lager findet einen prozess so
kurz vor wahlen unfair
das wird sich rächen am ende wird das
israelische volk sagen das ist nicht
fair und wir stehen hinter gittern
jahren der hat jedenfalls beantragen
lassen den prozess ein paar monate
auszusetzen
nach dem putsch in myanmar wird der
widerstand immer stärker hunderttausende
folgten einem aufruf zum generalstreik
und demonstrierten gegen die militärs
und die haben reagiert erstmals ließen
sie wasserwerfer auffahren und drohten
im staatsfernsehen mit harten maßnahmen
über die größten städte verhängten sie
eine ausgangssperre weiter ungeklärt ist
das schicksal der nobelpreisträgerin
aung san suu kyi nach der sturzflut
katastrophe im norden indiens gelten
mehr als 170 menschen noch immer als
vermisst
in den tödlichen wassermassen sind
bisher mindestens 26 menschen umgekommen
geflutet wurde auch der kilometerlange
tunnel eines elektrizitätswerkes in dem
zahlreiche männer gerade bauarbeiten aus
führten
dort wurde ein großteil der opfer
vermutet 25 von ihnen konnten bislang
gerettet werden zu dem unglück war es
gestern morgen gekommen als ein teil des
einander db gletschers im bundesstaat
utah erkannt abbrach und zwei flüsse in
sturzfluten verwandelte ja und wir sind
jetzt beim sport und den australian open
in melbourne
und da haben die deutschen tennisfrauen
einen ganz schlechten start erwischt
angelique kerber ist raus ebenso andrea
petkovic und auch laura siegemund besser
dagegen läuft es bei den männern dominik
koepfer weiter und alexander zverev
nervenstark alle anfang bei den
australian open war sichtlich schwer für
den 23 jährigen hamburger der gegen den
us amerikaner marcus gewinnt den ersten
satz im tie break verlor den zweiten
dann erneut im tie break für sich
entschied und von da an spiel und gegner
dominierte und das match nach vier
sätzen
mit einem rückhand return winner
beendete in der nächsten runde trifft
alexander zverev nun auf den franko
amerikaner maxime kresse dagegen war die
enttäuschung riesengroß bei angelique
kerber die gegen bern adapter aus den
usa gleich in runde 1 nicht den hauch
einer chance hatte und mit einer
frustrieren schwachen leistung in das
neue tennis jahr startet liverpools
titelverteidigung rückt nach der 1 4
heimniederlage gegen manchester city in
weite ferne
der star des abends dirk a junioren von
mancity zunächst verschießt er einen
elfer ja dann leitete aber mit seinem
doppelpack in der 49 und in der 73
minute den sieg ein
liverpool als vierter jetzt schon zehn
punkte hinter tabellenführer
mancity und vergangene nacht der super
bowl das finale der us-football-liga die
tampa bay buccaneers gegen den
titelverteidiger kansas city chiefs und
damit die quarterback superstar tom
brady gegen patrick mehr holmes die
gastgeber siegen haushoch 25.000
zuschauer dabei in tampa sehen neben
sport viel pathos aber auch momente des
innehaltens medizinisches personal
eingeladen von den teams anerkennung für
in der pandemie geleistete arbeit auf
dem feld dreht sich alles um ihn
tom brady siebter titel für den
erfolgreichsten fußballer der geschichte
brady führt seine buccaneers zum
deutlichen 31 zu 9 gegen kansas city
deren quarterback bettmar ums ohne
touchdown erstmals gewinnt ein heim team
den super bowl
tampa und brady schreiben geschichte an
einem besonderen tag und sarah thomas
hat auch geschichte geschrieben sie war
die erste schiedsrichterin war sehr
eindrucksvoll das wetter hält uns weiter
in atem
es wird jetzt sehr frostig und das
keineswegs nur nachts die einzelheiten
hat gleich katja honnefer das war es von
uns schön dass sie dabei waren
mehr gibt es im heute journal mit
marietta slomka um drei viertel 10
und wir sind morgen wieder für sie da
punkt 19 uhr bis dahin
[Musik]
er nahm meine damen und herren auch
heute hat es kräftig geschneit zum einen
hier zwischen berlin und dem münsterland
aber auch im südwesten
diese schneefälle zogen über baden
württemberg das saarland und
rheinland-pfalz weiter in richtung
nordosten und erreichen in der nacht
auch thüringen und sachsen dann
schneidet es in norddeutschland noch
kräftig weiter und es gibt die gefahr
einer ostsee sturmflut zwischen
timmendorf und flensburg an das wasser
einen meter höher auflaufen als möglich
und machen sie sich überall auf
winterliche straßenverhältnisse gefasst
besonders in der mitte da sinken die
temperaturen auf minus 13 bis minus 20
grad und steigen auch morgen über tag
nicht über minus 11 bis minus neun grad
besonders an der ostseeküste gibt es
morgen entspannendes phänomen da
ziemlich schneeschauer von der ostsee
herein und die können dann lokal eng
begrenzt noch mal 20 bis 40 zentimeter
neuschnee bringen
im binnenland zeigt sich häufiger die
sonne in sachsen sind einige
schneeschauer unterwegs genauso wie
südlich der donau in den nächsten tagen
geht es sehr winterlich weiter und bis
freitag setzt sich dann häufiger die
sonne durch schönen abend noch